oh what a waste you so much
alright we're back home but only for a
couple hours cuz we're gonna have to be
flying out to probably show pretty soon
yeah getting here we notice that there's
two packages waiting for us really
kritis to see what we got because we did
not order one of those short oh this is
oh yeah pizza now okay I want to eat
this pizza
we got the socks this is so cool what is
this oh my God thank you so much to
Giorno we honestly had no thing to hear
you guys were sending this but it's
actually perfect timing because now you
got me craving some pizza do you want to
make some pizza baby oh yeah you know
actually here for three hours coming
back from London from the whole Morocco
trip so we've decided to drop off some
stuff from our luggage spend some time
with the kitty cats and apparently now
we're about to make some pizzas
know what I realized
11:52 pit they gave us is circular
that's what it's called it's a bit I
think so isn't it call it pizza Pitt I
have no idea I don't know what that
thing is called no but you know it's
cool we actually don't need it because
the crispy pan pizza comes in in its own
pan so yeah oh my god yeah
how is that just though we need it for
this quick pit stop at home a little
piece of America hides after eating
lunch we're gonna repack our luggage
just consolidate to one and I'm gonna
show you guys how I organize our
suitcase it's for two trips 21 days
[Music]
right so since we were planning on just
going from Morocco straight to Croatia
we ended up packing everything for both
trips but then once we landed we
realized hey we got three hours to kill
let's go home see the kitties eat some
food drop off some Moroccan Sylvan ears
and consolidate our luggages to just be
one one big one and then to carry on so
that's the plan right now we're going to
do this so we can catch our flight -
holy sháá up and down looking these
things are rather than like so
cumbersome no cumbersome really yours
right yep
do you wanna go get the other one yeah
so me follow well you're actually
following me this never happens
cool you miss me huh they miss us
therefore following me
this never happens this is so cool you
following me yes that's it no more
yeah you're gonna escort me all the way
all right
all right so before we left or before we
got here we ended up consolidating all
of our dirty clothes so okay first of
all we use this space saver bag right to
make pecking easier and more effective
and so what we did was we got all of our
dirty clothes and we put it in one big
one so this guy right here so this is
dirty put it by the hamper it's so cool
how hard it's like the rock-solid
clean I don't know did you want to keep
this for Croatia yeah let's keep this
one this one I feel like nice come in
handy brand-new coat yeah I used to wait
loose I'm good yeah that's a dead lift
right there I'll show you some I got
this passion meeting that you guys saw
me get this one
beautiful passion beam okay
I'm so glad TIFF is so good at packing
because I'm just looking at this like
it's a headache me too okay but not
really because I actually really enjoy
Korea here all my shoes I think I can
consolidate I make sure to bring a lot
of it's like all these to Morocco I
didn't even wear these but I was
planning for Croatia
that's why oh it's true though I don't
need these I definitely don't need these
look how dirty they are they saw this
the heart does around them ooh a little
piece of Sahara
[Music]
what do mmm like you're gonna eat it
nauseous memories on the bottom of your
shoe you know I was reading I got an
article on how to pack properly for 21
days
because I was trying to help you this is
I read this article before we left for
Morocco in it it said to pack no more
than two pairs of shoes two pairs yes
for 21 no and this is a girl it is the
girls blog that was reading it she's
like don't pack more than 2 shoes if
they eat up the most space looking
either the loot bag you're like holy
crap hey but I made it all work alright
you didn't make it work where'd you get
the idea to do this paper bags I have
common sense we never thought about they
say yes I do have a baby you know coming
with just not as good as yours yeah I
don't know I thought it was just it
makes sense
so you make it really really condensed
but you know what though it has been
kind of a backfire because every time we
go through customs and I have a space
saver bag in my carry-on
they're always like what is this brick
thing I know it like slows down our time
through the customs and TSA not always
oh my god do we tell them about the
drone no the drums alright so we were to
leave in Morocco and okay one thing
about drones is that you won when you
travel internationally with drones
you're supposed to get a what the total
is that Turnbull
license permit permission license permit
permission yes and we did for Croatia
and we do owe authorization we didn't
get a authorized yes has no intentions
of using the drone in Morocco at all we
were just taking it because like I said
we thought we were gonna go we we didn't
even think we were gonna come home so we
were just taking everything that we were
gonna take to Croatia we took the drum
with us we entered Morocco no problem
no one said anything about the drone but
then when we were leaving more elko all
of a sudden now they want to confiscate
the drone and we're like no but we need
it we need it for Croatia with you for
the next trip we need it for our job and
then they started telling us like well
you know if you had this in Egypt just
by having it with you you could have up
to two years in prison really from a
drone that's crazy but you know what
fine we respect other countries laws
that's fine but I think the the part
that really hurts me was like relieving
your country and now you want to take it
that's the part that I just could not it
and I could have taken it when we
entered the country and I think that
would have actually sad better with me
oh we can't bring it in
I'm sorry no problem here keep it can we
take it when we're leaving your country
but don't confiscate it when we're
leaving your anyway so yes we had it off
there as well Croatia sorry guys we were
gonna give you guys a whole bunch of
beautiful drone footage of Croatia and
yeah we can't lesson learned lesson
learned shoes clothes and bags jackets
punk no we're done that was hard work
wasn't it
okay you did so much work let me show
you the missing drone though yeah
misson drone it was supposed to be in
here
you got this the charger thing that you
hook up to the wall and then we have
this beautiful bag drone bag nothing it
has nothing in it the officer that
confiscated it he took the drone and the
one battery that was attached to the
drone but then his superior which is
like where's the propellers there's the
rest of it we get the whole thing yeah
cuz we were hella stall t something
confiscated we're like oh so they need
the propellers too huh huh well we are
you checked in our bags it has doll the
drone stuff no well we've got that
propeller still they can't use I mean
they could easily probably just but
anyway moving off from the drummer
selfie obviously but you know what else
is funny that you have in your carry-on
that's useless
what so I bought this travel steamer
before going on our trip because
obviously all of our clothes are very
wrinkled with the airbags I kept using
the steamer and it worked perfectly fine
look it's a very good one
no pun and only time my beautiful
husband here used it it broke and we
were left and you know what's funny
hold on come back over here you know
it's funny so I used this once in
Morocco it worked fine then Casey goes
over he plugs it back in and fills it
back in everything he's about to use it
turns on the light the lights on and it
never heats up I'm like how did you
break it like how did you do that so now
we were I thought of a steamer and so
that's why when we were coming this way
what we were still in London I ended up
ordering on Amazon a new steamer and
that's the little box that we have so
now we're gonna pack that and hopefully
that can work for Croatia but let's
focus on the positives here yeah was it
my fault
yes it wasn't your fault let's see what
happens with another brand of a
different steamer let's see Oh cute it's
smaller than you oh no it's the same
size but it looks more like as it's like
I think you are such a great
travel buddy to have because you're so
good at figuring out all these little
tricks to traveling lightly and
efficiently yeah show them my iridescent
bag that you didn't even know it
iridescent meant let's focus on the
positive in my favor these plugs which
we had three of these what are you HOT
the one so we lost one of our European
plug so TIFF is obviously the perfect
travel buddy cuz she has all the tricks
up her sleeve
and I am the worst travel buddy because
I break all the tricks in asleep you're
breaking you lose things yes okay I love
you yeah and then I also bought these
guys these like twisty thingies for all
the cords I like to be very organized if
you haven't noticed my iridescent bag
you know sweating is so cute because we
were in Paris and I asked Casey I was
like Casey can you get the plug out of
the iridescent bag he was like doesn't
what is that what does that mean where's
that is it the clear bag is it the black
bag like you don't know what era doesn't
mean I've never bothered to have
anything now zero doesn't so I don't
know you're so cute
it's fine ooh and then this day I bought
this super cute tiny little hair dryer
that Gio told me about Castillo thought
one of these a long long time ago she
was like oh my god this is so cute and
tiny you would love it that was a huge
hit with our travel buddies in Morocco
by the way yeah everyone in the tour
group they all anytime someone needed a
hairdryer
they'd be like to make every bar your
hairdryer that's how you make friends I
know I'm one of those tours have a
hairdryer all of my things though it
needs to go in bags if you can tell like
everything needs to be like sectioned
off and tiny little bags like giving up
my makeup like I have this bag inside of
this bag so that's the key guys the key
to be organized is put things in bags
kind of like that with my computer stuff
yeah you're organizing that sense the
key to being organized on your computer
is to put folders inside folders inside
focus oh look and we brought Sandford
Isaac from the Sahara Desert I didn't
take it someone else from the tour group
took it and said here for your son and I
call it thank you so much so that was
not am i doing
you don't need British Pamela I want
money
this is British pals it's called pretty
and brand-new and soft British pounds
are oh yeah so I really like British
money it's so nice Isaac's gonna get a
kick out of this cuz he's like obsessed
with England with England so he's gonna
love this
oh it's too bad that we can't meet up
with Isaac - oh I know I forgot to
mention in the vlog but Isaac's actually
he went somewhere with his dad right now
in this like moment cuz we like I said
we did not plan on coming home so we
didn't even tell him that we were gonna
come home cuz if we would have then we
could have planned better and we would
have been seeing him right now - so
finish packing everything I'm gonna jump
in the shower just take a quick body
shower dang I got dizzy I got up too
fast I got away too fast look at though
he missed us he missed his mama
I think right now that I'm laying down
and I'm not on the move like I feel it
like the tiredness because I'm already
used to the other timezone so we're
technically supposed to be asleep right
now
yeah very go sleep right
why are you so cute - stop it stop it
that's her way of saying stay home I
don't want to leave them right now oh no
you guys that is how we sleep all the
time okay the water spilled food spills
you losers are good we're nice and clean
three packs you ready baby no one let's
go by with a kitty cat look at that he's
like you guys are leaving I'm gonna miss
you we're gonna be back in it just two
more weeks okay he's gonna never home
he's mad at me
you're just cuddling with me a second
ago
[Music]
so we just flew into Croatia
we're in Zagreb so exciting
[Music]